what's happening there reject nation
craig good job here we're showing
something a little bit special and then
this came out while i was in the middle
of editing it tom holland zadeh and
jacob i'm assuming battle on react to
the spider-man no way home trailer too
it's only like 30 seconds long and came
out of the cosmic water channel one of
those videos like re-uploaded to his
page i was like
we gotta watch it yeah of course we
gotta watch this you gotta watch them
react to what we can't even see trailer
two tomorrow people
[Music]
what up guys we're about to watch the
new trailer i'm quite nervous actually
oh oh oh
oh
get it oh
do it my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
people are gonna go crazy when they see
that bit oh my goodness
they weren't really watching anything
they don't think they were
going this has got to be like a green
box it's got a desktop it's not even on
there were tires especially with jacob
paddle on it you can see him like
looking over at them yeah oh
am i selling this one or what guys
[Laughter]
that's crazy right it's crazy right
there are times that where i was super
top holland especially are they watching
some videos jacob battle all that happy
kind of questioning whether or not
they're really watching something yeah
he's easily the most enthused but
congratulations to everyone who got
tickets to that fan event i know some
people who are actually going but yeah
keep a lookout for a reaction to
whatever they were watching here maybe
this was a real reaction i'm totally
wrong about that it's a 30-second
trailer sometimes when i guess when
something's fake it ends up being real
what do you know they're gonna come out
with a whole other reverse angle version
of this video just to prove it but if it
is real then even better even better
than they are just as excited as they
ought to be guys keep a lookout for our
video tomorrow see you guys soon